deep in the heart of Witchita Kansas
lies the most powerful oil Dynasty in
America and no it's not the Rockefellers
this family's business makes twice what
Coca-Cola makes or around $125 million a
year they're the second largest
privately owned company in America and
the current patriarch of the family he
ranks as the 22nd richest person in the
world this family operates oil
refineries in Alaska Texas Minnesota and
other states that means they control
4,000 Mi of pipeline longer than the
United States itself they built oil
refineries for Joseph Stalin Hitler they
for Qatar and being how much America
loves his
oil you can bet that this means they
have a lot of political sway in American
politics and indeed they do this family
ranked as the 15th largest donor in the
2022 election cycle while also ranking
as the 26th biggest lobbyist in America
they are not shy about using their
wealth to mold America to their heart's
desire but it's not just oil in politics
you probably have some of their products
in your home right now as we speak if
you've ever wor a lyar product cleaned
up with a brownie paper towel stood on a
stained Master carpet or drunk from a
Dixie cup you have used their products
and yet most of you have probably never
heard of their name and if you have you
probably don't know anything about them
and for good reason they don't like
giving interviews they definitely don't
do social media which seems pretty
logical because if you have interest in
oil Wars and you're supporting overseas
dictators you would probably want to
stay out of the Limelight as well who is
this powerful family you ask well move
aside Rockefeller because it's none
other than the coke family the most
powerful oil Dynasty in American
[Music]
today the Koch family has a lot of
different skills the oil business the
paper business marketing and much more
in fact if you look at a lot of the
people you look up to you'll find that
most of them are good at many different
skills which is why you should always be
learning and a great place to learn new
skills is skillshare skillshare is an
online learning community with thousands
of classes raging from AI to
entrepreneurship to storytelling and
Digital Arts for example Ali abell's
class productivity for creators was very
helpful for for a person in my position
and his lesson on productive
procrastination blew my mind but
skillshare isn't just for Content
creators or productivity hackers it's
for anyone who likes to learn new things
you can discover classes for something
as specific as 3D illustration for
interior design as well as lessons on
something as broad as how to make
friends there's over 200 classes on side
hustles and making money online and the
best part is that you can start
risk-free with the link below the first
500 people to use my link will get a one
Monon free trial of skillshare so pause
the video and click the link below now
and thanks to skillshare for sponsoring
this
video coat Harry Koke was a Dutch
immigrant born in 1867 that moved to
America at the age of 21 and Harry Cook
was a very entrepreneurial Man by the
time he moved to a small town in Texas
called kuana he spent his time saving
enough money to buy a local newspaper
that would turn into the quana Tribune
Chief but he didn't stop there he would
then get into the railroad business
starting the quana Acme and Pacific
Railway company as well so with the
newspaper and railroad business in hand
he would use the newspaper to promote
his Railroad and he would also use the
newspaper to spread his libertarian
political beliefs he would use the paper
to criticize Social Security he would
trash unions and be very Pro business
and this would be the humble beginnings
of his families foray into politics it
will also be the humble beginnings of
what will become known as Coke
Industries Harry wanted to turn his
little town of quana into the most
important railroad Center in that part
of Texas he wanted to turn it into a
major metropolitan area but
unfortunately he would never quite
achieve that dream but he sure did make
a whole lot of money in the process he
would pass the Reigns over to his son
Fred kooch and Fred also shared his
father's ambition and he would take Koch
Industries to a whole another
[Music]
level it was the oil boom in Texas at
the time so Fred over here decided to
expand his father's business into oil he
ended up allegedly copying an oil
refining process that was recently
invented by a company called Universal
products and he quickly started making
bank off off of it he started installing
his copycat Refinery products all over
the Midwest and business was booming
until Universal products sued him in
1929 for copyright infringement suddenly
Fred's business was in Jeopardy he
needed to find a way to keep making
money so he thought to himself hm
American copyright laws are just that
American other far off countries aren't
going to care if they're breaking
American intellectual property laws so
to continue making money all he would
need to do is find people in other
countries in need of his oil refining
services that also don't care about us
laws hm people like
[Music]
dictators so Fred decided to head off to
the Soviet Union to help out who do you
know Joseph Stalin yes Fred went to the
Soviet Union to help out Joseph Stalin
set up 15 oil refineries in the 1930s
before World War II and it worked the
oil refineries were a success and Stalin
paid him Millions
but Stalin also wound up imprisoning and
executing some of Fred's Soviet
co-workers which obviously wasn't ideal
way to show gratitude Stalin so Fred
bucked it out of the Soviet Union and it
left him with a deep hatred for
communism so since the Soviet Union
wasn't an option anymore he went to the
next logical customer Hitler yes a few
years later Fred would go to Germany to
build oil refineries for Adolf Hitler
Fred wasn't a Nazi but he was a
capitalist and adolf's money was as good
as anyone else's check out our private
documentary on whether or not Hitler
actually killed himself by clicking the
card on the top right corner in the end
Fred came back from Europe as a very
rich man and he proceeded to do what any
man would do after getting rich selling
oil refineries to homicidal Maniacs he
got married and started a family Fred
met his wife Mary in a 1930s polo match
he then built a massive Mansion near the
Witchita Country Club in Kansas and he
quickly started having Sons these Sons
the third generation of the Koch Dynasty
would go on to grow his empire into what
it is today there were four sons in
total Frederick Charles and two twins
David and Bill and this was not an easy
household to grow up in they lived under
super strict rules in fact David and
Bill were often encouraged to Duke it
out with each other when they were
children to settle their differences in
fact here's a video of the unboxing
after all if his sons were to grow up to
take over the Empire they would have to
be tough how tough are you but little
did Fred know that this ultra
competitive upbringing would later rip
his sons apart but in the meantime Fred
was still in charge and his Empire was
growing by leaps and bounds by the time
World War II was over Fred had built a
mass International conglomerates they
were doing business in 50 different
countries he kept expanding into oil but
he also got into the paper business the
synthetics business the fertilizer
business and even into Banking and he
would use all this influence to fight
back against those damn
[Music]
commies see money is one thing but now
that Fred had all the money in the world
he wanted real power so following
following in his Father's Footsteps he
got into politics he became one of the
founders of the ultraconservative John
BR society which was a super
anti-communist group they specialized in
propagating the fear of a communist
Takeover in America they even thought
President Eisenhower was a communist
agent even though he was one of the guys
that helped win World War II red cook
wasn't a fan of the Civil Rights
Movement either he believed that black
people were supporting a communist
Takeover in America he predicted that
communist would infiltrate the American
government and he feared that a future
president of the US would be a secret
communist so yeah the F of communism at
the time were coarsing through his veins
it influenced everything he did and it
would have a massive effect on his sons
when Fred kooch died in 1967 his sons
inherited the Koke Empire with Charles
and David taking over running the actual
company and these Sons would bring the
shadiness to a whole new
level the OPEC oil embargo of the 1970s
hit Coke hard at the time Coke
Industries had already invested half a
billion dollars in five super tankers
that were supposed to be delivering OPEC
oil to America but when the Embargo hit
the oil stopped which meant they were
bleeding money every single day so to
try to recoup some of the money Coke
Industries decided to overcharge
American customers for oil but
eventually they would be caught in 1974
President Ford forced Koch to pay back
more than $20 million in rebates and
future oil price reductions which to be
fair was pennies for them but it didn't
stop there in the late 1970s the federal
government was giving out exploration
tracks for oil with a lottery system
where you could get a 10-year lease at
just $1 an acre if you won the lottery
the idea was to give the wouldbe oil
Prospectors the same shot at getting
some land like the big players like
kooch but Koke didn't like these odds so
coke got a bunch of people to place bids
on their behalf if they won they would
transfer the leases over to the kokes a
clever plan that was busted in 1980 when
Coke Industries had to plead guilty to
five felonies in federal court including
conspiracy to commit fraud in the five
decades Charles cook was in charge of
the Empire the company was paying out
record levels of penalties basically any
Shady thing they could do they were
probably doing it including backstabbing
their own blood in 1983 a power struggle
ensued with the Koch brothers in the end
Frederick and Bill were kicked out of
coke Industries leaving with a sence of
$800 million or $2.3 billion in today's
money which all being said is not that
bad but in Frederick and Bill's eyes
they felt ripped off everything they
worked for their family's Legacy had
been ripped away from them so Bill Bill
decided to fight back Bill ended up
hiring private detectives to look into
Charles wrongdoings of which there were
many Bill even went as far as to drag
Charles to court and to even subpoena
his own mother his mother by the way had
just had a stroke needless to say the
two men have not spoken for decades not
even at their own mother's
[Music]
funeral in the '90s a Coke pipeline
exploded burning two Texas teenagers to
death investigators found hundreds of
holes in the faulty pipeline running
near a residential area Coke Industries
only fixed a few dozen so they were hit
with the largest wrongful death Judgment
of his type in US history nearly $300
million just a year later Coke
Industries have to pay quote the largest
fine ever imposed on a company $30
million for more than 300 oil spills the
refineries have been responsible for End
quotes that's 3 million gallons of oil
spilled in Six States but let's face it
the money they made from these 3 oil
spills far exceeded this measly $30
million fine fines are just a cost of
doing business and what they don't spill
they steal as much as 300 million
gallons of oil was stolen off of federal
lands in the 1980s by the Koch brothers
earning them $230 million in profit
according to Bill Koke himself and he
lied about it to Regulators 24,000 times
and if that wasn't bad enough a lot of
that oil came off of Native American
tribal lands why because stealing oil
from these areas is a lot easier since
the government wasn't really watching
and what they don't steal they pollute
they've dumped oil refining byproducts
where they're not supposed to or take
this paper mill from the paper GI
Georgia Pacific for example Georgia
Pacific is owned by Coke Industries and
they make products like Brony Dixie
Angel Soft and more but what you may not
know is that making paper products is
actually a very toxic process which is
why according to the EPA this paper mill
emits 1.5 million pounds of toxic
chemicals every single year including
for Malahide and chloroform all this
toxic waste for a small workingclass
town of just 5,2 200 residents the
rivers are smelly the air is smelly qu
when the wind is blowing the wrong way
it brings a harsh metallic smell into
the homes of nearby residents a strong
wol stings the nose and burns the throat
and lungs end quote according to
Residents many locals have died of
cancer and the pollution just keeps on
flowing according to the University of
Massachusetts Amherst the three worst
air polluters in America are Exon Mobile
American Electric Power and you guessed
it Coke Industries Coke Industries DS
more pollution into the nation's
waterways then General Electric and
International Paper combined which
probably explains why they're constantly
throwing money at
[Music]
politicians many rich people donate to
politicians but the CES they've created
their own political group called
Americans for Prosperity or AFP which is
ironic given all the misery they've
caused AFP is one of the most
influential American conservative
organizations but they're actually very
libertarian they're against wasteful
government spending corporate handouts
which I support but they also push the
stuff you would expect like things that
favor their pollution but the coke
Dynasty does not stop there now every
year the coch brothers host an annual
meeting with only the most rich and
Powerful think of it as kind of like
their own version of Davos or the wef
they got the 400 to 450 super rich
people these people include at least 18
billionaires one researcher estimates
that the net worth of these people comes
out to over $200 billion take for
example in in 2014 when the coch
brothers hosted their annual summer
seminar in Dana Point California at a
super Swanky St rg's Resort security was
tight attendees had escorts from Coke
Industries and everyone had to give up
their mobile phones some sources said
there might have been 300 billionaires
there which would have been over half
the number of billionaires in the
country back then so what does the Koch
Dynasty have in store for us next well
with the biggest election year coming up
in 2024 you can bet that they're hard at
work trying to pull the strings with one
of their main goals being to ensure that
Trump does not get the nomination
[Music]